how many operating rooms do you have
here so we have six operating rooms it
should be busy in these hallways dr gary
weinberg is the chief of surgery at
cornwall community hospital right now
only one of his operating rooms is
running with ontario postponing elective
surgeries five operating rooms are empty
well it's horrible you know it's 1 20 in
the afternoon right now normally this
room should be full of hustle and bustle
patients getting the care they need
all right just relax your arm there now
weinberg says shutting down was like
cutting off an arm to save the rest of
the body very hard choices had to be
made the staff was needed in other parts
of the hospital to keep it going the
acute medicine unit would normally have
12 nurses they've had days where five
were off sick with covid that's a
patient to nurse ratio the director of
the department calls unsafe it has
reached that level
knock on wood we're not there this week
you know what i'm going to check your
chart right now in the hospital 38 staff
members are off sick the rest have
already had kovid or basically they're
waiting to get it for the first time
i've been sick
a lot of my co-workers have been sick to
take some of the burden off people like
nurse kelly lozon for the last few weeks
the hospital has redeployed staff that
would normally be working off-site this
woman's not a nurse she's a warehouse
worker the extra hands were needed that
desperately you know we're going into
year three now of this
exhausting
doesn't seem like there's any end in
sight
pre-pandemic the cch already ran near or
over capacity it used to have 156 beds
it's added 22. it literally says it over
the door yes the auditorium isn't an
auditorium right now it holds 11
patients there's no place to bed space
them anywhere else there's a struggle in
intensive care as well this fifth wave
has been the toughest
so right now we're at 13 patients
admitted to a 12 bed unit
so we're over capacity every day it's
been this way the last few weeks there
are days where every single patient in
this icu is here due to covid and the
unvaccinated are over represented one
nurse told us she'd like to give some
sort of covered tours so people could
see what's going on but it would be too
dangerous for people to visit where she
works every day
mike armstrong global news cornwall
ontario